Looking to get high on a new water sport.
Well, you literally can riding a flying
water bike.
It attaches with a long hose to the back of
a jet ski, elevating you up to almost 40ft
above the water where you can perform aerial
flips and spins.
The jet skis, water thrust feeds three jet
nozzles on the flying water bike.
One propels the bike upward, the other two
feed jet control nozzles that maneuver the
bike. The bike's frame is made out of
aluminum parts because it has to be
lightweight as well as relatively corrosion
resistant, especially if it's going to be
used in salt water.
This curved tube will become the lifting jet
to build each jet control nozzle.
A worker places a housing on an alignment
fixture, then hammers an end cap into
position, holding the housing steady with a
clamp.
The worker welds on the end cap.
This housing will cover the bushing at the
heart of the jet control nozzle.
He inserts an elbow into the opening in the
end cap and welds the parts together.
After welding a jet nozzle cone to the other
end of the elbow, he welds a handlebar to the
housing. These five welded parts make up the
body of the first jet control nozzle.
To prep for painting the manufacturers rough
up all the aluminum parts by tumbling them
with abrasive stones.
This component splits the portion of the
water thrust that bypasses the lifting jet,
sending it in opposite directions to the jet
control nozzles.
The lift and jet tube now has a nozzle cone
welded to one end.
A coupling for attaching the fire hose to the
other and an oval hole in the curve which
aligns with the angled end of a straight
tube in the middle called the backbone.
After positioning parallel support bars
between the lifting jet and the splitter, the
welder fuses all the parts together.
Then he flips the assembly jig and welds on
the seat support.
The seat support attaches where the lifting
jet and backbone meet.
After masking the ends of the splitter, a
worker sprays the completed frame, jet
control nozzles and other aluminum parts
with powder coat.
This helps protect against corrosion.
The parts go into an oven for up to a half
hour to bake.
The powder coat to a shiny finish.
Then workers install an aluminum cam lock to
securely fasten the fire hose to the
coupling. Another worker attaches the
remaining components to the frame.
First, he screws in the pair of foot plates
on which the rider stands.
Then he bolts the bottom half of each plate
to the parallel support bars and the top half
to just ahead of the cam lock.
He mounts a padded knee rest to the support
bars.
It can be easily repositioned to accommodate
the rider's height.
On each unpainted end of the splitter, he
installs an internal support ring, then a
precision fit nylon bushing and an external
support ring which he screws to the splitter.
The worker slides the jet control nozzle
housing over the bushing and screws it to the
internal support ring.
The two control nozzles maneuver the water
bike to ascend.
You pull back gradually on both of them
simultaneously to descend.
You push forward on both to spin.
You move one forward and one back and to do
a backflip.
You yank both control nozzles all the way
back.
He assembles the water bike's body.
It's made of molded polyethylene with a
waterproof urethane pad to cushion the front
of the rider's body.
The seat is made of the same padded
material, both pad and seat attach with
plastic clips.
The hollow body is completely watertight,
which is why the bike floats.
The final step is to mate the body to the
frame.
The completed water bicycle weighs £30.
Once connected to a jet ski with a fire
hose, this water bike flies at a speed of up
to 20mph.
By maneuvering the jet nozzles, it does
backflips, multiple spins and even dives 20ft
under water. A throttle position sensor
reports the position of the throttle plate to
the engine computer so that it can decide
how much fuel to inject into the engine and
many other things.
Without this critical sensor, the ratio of
the air fuel mix would be compromised and the
engine would likely stall.
An internal combustion engines.
The throttle position sensor is on constant
alert, sensing the necessary power demands to
ensure a smooth ride.
Making these sensors starts with printed
circuit boards.
These boards will ultimately process
physical data and convert this into
information the engine computer will
understand.
A robot transfers the boards to a conveyor,
which takes them to a solder screen printer.
The printer squeegee solder through a
stencil to deposit it in specific locations
on the boards.
The squeegee and stencil then retract and
the conveyor shoves the boards forward to the
next operation.
Here, a robot retrieves electronic
components from tape on a reel and deposits
them on the solder spots on the boards.
It collects multiple parts from the reel at
one time and installs them on the boards
faster than you can blink an eye.
Moving forward, the printed circuit boards
arrive at a camera station.
The camera clicks away and sends pictures of
the boards to a computer.
The computer analyzes the placement of each
component with the computer's.
Okay. The boards head into an oven with
different heating zones.
The oven melts the solder and then cools it
down to fuse the components to the boards.
The oven that ejects the censor boards.
Next, a technician serves them up to
automated test probes.
The probes energize the components on the
boards and in the process collect
information. They send the data to a
computer which analyzes the function of the
components on the board and to make sure
they're fully operational.
Then the boards move to a pneumatic punch.
It separates the 18 sensor circuit boards by
cutting the tabs that hold them together.
A worker assembles a metal spring to a
plastic magnet holder.
He places a high wear washer over the neck
of the magnet holder.
Then he inserts the magnet holder assembly
into the throttle sensor housing and places
the unit in a tray.
After glue has been injected in the holders,
a robot moves in.
It scans the holders and confirms that
there's glue in each cavity.
It then inserts magnets in the holders.
A worker installs a torsion spring in the
housing.
It will hold the magnet holder tight to the
throttle body.
He now inserts the printed circuit boards
into the sensor housings terminals in the
housings made two slots in the boards.
He solders the terminals to the boards to
establish the connections.
All the parts are now in place for throttle
position sensing.
A worker places covers over the sensor board
compartments.
An ultrasonic welder, then melts the plastic
at the interfaces.
Once it hardens the weld bonds, the cover to
the sensor body.
A robot pipes silicone adhesive on the
welded seam to create a double layer of
protection. The sensors ride on a conveyor
that goes through an oven.
This cures both the silicone on the welded
seam and the glue inside to secure the magnet
to the holder out of the oven.
The sensors travel through a cooling
station.
Probes, then power the devices and calibrate
them for use in specific vehicles.
A robot holds the sensor in front of a laser
which etches the date of manufacture back on
a conveyor. The throttle position sensor
travels under a magnifying glass so that the
laser etching job can be scrutinised.
This throttle position sensor is now ready
for detection duty.